taxes locaux que pierre karl péladeau a
acheté en 2019 s'associe à n'être lift
qui a développé une plateforme de
covoiturage
les deux entreprises vont mettre en
commun leurs systèmes informatiques pour
l'ensemble des taxis du québec taq celle
qu gère une flotte de 1500 véhicule taxi
hochelaga et diamond pierre karl
péladeau compte remettre en circulation
les véhicules électriques de théo taxi
qui a cessé ses activités il y a un an
le consumer electronics show l'un des
événements les plus importants dans le
monde des technologies se déroule
présentement à las vegas au nevada
ce salon attire plus de 170 mille
personnes via skype ce soir on retrouve
pascal forget chroniqueur à planète
techno sur ici explora qui sous le chaud
soleil de las vegas bon soit pascal
bonsoir je suis content de vous parler
ben oui j'imagine bien vous êtes
contents d'être là aussi est de voir les
nouveautés
beaucoup de nouveautés à chaque année
cette année a beaucoup de téléviseurs
n'est ce pas oui mais comme d'habitude
c'est toujours ce qui vole un peu le
spectacle des téléviseurs de plus en
plus minces de plus en plus performants
cette année on met beaucoup de l'avant
lui vite qu une résolution encore plus
élevé ceux qui ont toujours des télés hd
vont commencer à voir vite changer
évidemment le contenu n'est pas encore
disponible mais ça s'en vient on voit
aussi des téléviseurs qui pivote de 90°
qui vont permettre de détecter
automatiquement le contenu file mr et
verticale question de profiter de ses
vidéos en pleine résolution et donc
c'est qui qui offre cela lg samsung
notamment chez samsung met de l'avant
cette ellipse heure là d'ailleurs
samsung met de l'avant sont énormes et
téléviseurs de 280 12 pouces de
diagonale 7.5 m c'est presque deux
étages de haut est évidemment la
résolution est fantastique et aucune
bordures et on peut empiler ces modules
erp donc on peut changer la taille du
téléviseur selon ses besoins
les ordinateurs aussi ont des écrans
surdimensionné innovateur également
également qu est ce que vous avez vu
c'est quelque chose de fantastique on
peut
son ordinateur portable et il ya deux
écrans ou du moins il ya un seul écran
flexible qui permet d'avoir toutes les
surfaces de son ordinateur portable un
écran flexible ultra mince et même les
nouveaux que tu acceptes ce type
d'ordinateur l' offre aussi un
ordinateur avec une un écran papier
électronique à l'extérieur donc ça
consomme peu d'énergie et ça permet de
consulter ses rendez-vous ou de s'en
servir comme liseuse même quand on a
notre ordinateur et fermer complètement
et c'est absolument nouveau ça cette
année
ouais ben c'est quelque chose qui
surprend le fait qu'on a deux écrans
maintenant et le géant propose samsung
en propre aux oies oui on propose donc
avoir des écrins salle toujours plus dur
en mai qui vont se replier pour prendre
moins de place dans son sac dans sa
poche on quand on parle de technologie
on voit bien sur ces objets on parle de
téléviseurs on parle d'ordinateurs mais
il ya aussi de la technologie d'un
secteur de l'alimentation qu'est ce qui
a attiré votre attention de ce côté
c'est assez particulier comme quoi
l'alimentation on n'associe pas
nécessairement ça la technologie mais on
entre au dessus un frigo qui permet de
ne pas pousser sa nourriture chez soi et
aussi la compagnie aime pas ce beau foot
qui profitent du cs pour lancer son
substitut des viandes qui ressemble à du
port alors il ya de longues files
d'attentes pour goûter à des hamburgers
qui goûtent à tue pas mais en plus on
pourrait s'en servir pour faire des
tourtières ou des petites bouchées
c'était assez surprenant les faits et
c'est moins gras et évidemment ils pas
d'animaux donc c'est végétarien
virtuellement ouais c'est ça le cs le
consumer electronics show se met au vert
organisme en est et parce que c'est une
tendance quand même très très fort
parlons un peu de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la connexion 5,5 g
également au rendez vous est ce que le
québec qui représente et oui on parle de
plus en plus des intelligences
artificielles dans les appareils d
intelligence a retiré le plus en plus
sophistiqué ayant lg qui annonce un
partenariat avec l'entreprise
montréalaise et l'emmental pour
améliorer l'intelligence artificielle
dans leur téléphone on a parlé avec un
des représentants de la compagnie le
cofondateur
et nous disait que si quelques années on
devrait voir les résultats de ce
partenariat la pleinement déployée il
pourrait peut-être y avoir un peu de
montréal est un peu d'éléments teai sur
les téléphones lg et on profite du
consumer electronic show aussi pas
seulement pour des produits mais aussi
pour faire des annonces notamment google
où elle est entre autres la ville de
paris qui annonçait que des aisselles
est fait pour des véhicules entièrement
autonome des taxis dans la ville de
paris donc le rêve de la voiture qui a
pas besoin conducteurs se rapprochent
véritablement il ya aussi toutes sortes
d'annoncés avec entre autres la
compagnie québécoise leddartech tu paies
des pièces des capteurs tu utilises le
laser ou au lieu du radar qui dans
toutes sortes de véhicules dans le salon
il ya de boxe aussi une boîte
réutilisables super intelligente comment
ça marche
c'est assez fantastique c'est la poste
française qui lance une voix qui est
réutilisable on fait de plus en plus
d'achats sur internet
donc cette boîte l'a peut être réutilisé
plus de mille fois
elle contient des capteurs qui
permettent de s'assurer que notre
contenu n'a pas été malmené au même un
gps pour s'assurer que le colis est aidé
au bon endroit et on peut tout
simplement réutiliser la boîte l'a
renvoyé et à la fin de sa vie ont pu
tout simplement faire une petite mise au
point et l'art est envoyé au
consommateur ça permet d'économiser 90 %
du matériel d'emballage intéressant là
on a un aperçu de ce que vous de ce qui
se passe présentement vous avez
enregistré sur place deux émissions de
planète techno quand pourrons nous voir
ses émissions
c'est le 17 et le 24 janvier à 19h sur i
see explorera et il ya tellement de
choses qu'on a vécu je pense que ça va
alors la bête de regarder pascal forget
à las vegas merci merci beaucoup